today's topic strangers rank their
intelligence me and preach are going to
watch it together
should we just like go down and do
intros yeah i'm chad
i'm 24 i work in finance i have a
bachelor's degree
i went to yale i'm tyler i'm 21 i'm a
high school graduate
and i work in the marine corps i'm
kaylie i'm 25
i'm a software developer i went to ohio
university and i have a bachelor's
degree
maria i'm 30 years old i have my phd in
cancer biology
and i work in a biotech industry grad
school i went to university of south
carolina and undergrad i went to
university of florida
hi my name is my little pony welcome
everybody
everybody my name is sean i'm 27 i'm the
director of social media for a company
and i also work for
ad agency i got a double major in dance
and cultural anthropology
undergrad i went to loyola marymount
university hi everybody i'm ray
i'm 24. i graduated with a bachelor's
degree in hybrid recently and i work in
consulting
all younger babies i know this thing is
age
factor i think intelligence is better
defined as your adaptability
and your problem solving skills more
than it is your education
obviously like the education the stuff
you've been through puts a lot on to
playing it because it gives you more
resources more
thoughts to draw from the formal
education definitely helps but
i don't think it's in any way essential
so what is the most ascension
so the most essential thing was probably
common sense iq short for intelligence
quotient is a measure of a person's
reasoning and ability in short it's
supposed to gauge how well someone can
use information and logic to answer
questions or make predictions
predictions i.e problem solving skills
so i think he had the right or he had
the right definition from what i could
see yeah so for me personally i think
intelligence is both eq iq and that
common sense
street smart intelligence all of that
combined okay so i did that eq
right eq is emotional intelligence
people use that you're very
emotionally intelligent i understand eq
is not actually a recognized term it's
not recognized by scientific community
it was invented by a journalist okay
just for those people who keep saying it
actually oh apparently jordan p
peterson's when he said this
there's no such thing as eq let me
repeat there is no such thing as eq the
idea was popularized
by a journalist daniel goldman not a
psychologist you can't just invent a
trait you have to define it measure it
and distinguish it from other traits and
use it to predict the important ways the
people vary
people consciously or unconsciously when
they see someone form an opinion
immediately like i'm sure we all did
right away when i saw you
i told myself maria do not judge him
just by his looks
he could be throwing you off or that's
just who he is
but he can talk to talk and walk the
walk
he could be throwing you off trying to
say i keep today
trying to look stupid or he could just
be really stupid
sean i didn't want to judge him based on
the way he looks or dresses or acts so i
was like i think he's intelligent but
still
judging him if you're saying i'm not
trying to judge you based off how you
look so i'm going to say you're smart
you are still inferring a judgment based
off of that it's still prejudicial
in that sense which is okay this is a
part of the whole game because the word
is not a good word
people don't like that word so what is
the definition that we're going with
is the biggest question i like your
definition i just say i like my
definition
it combines everything my first job out
of college i was working on a law firm
gentleman came up to me and said hi um
you don't look like somebody that would
work at a law firm you look like
somebody i'd go on spring break with
not even go in front you still look like
that
[Music]
[Laughter]
cabo obviously out of everyone here i've
got the least formal education
i consider myself intelligent my mental
dedication and my ability to
adapt and to problem solve what i do in
the marine corps i'm a
seber defense specialist so i think that
by virtue of what i do that already
requires
some amount of intelligence sorry quick
question so do you think that
only certain people can do your job or
do you think anyone can do your job
only certain people why don't you guys
rank each other from one to six
including yourself
and give reasons why you want to do what
you're doing you already know the white
people come in at last
you already know listen listen whitey's
stay in your corner
i gotta go one no oh yeah two
three four five
six i would rank you as a six not
meaning that you're not intelligent
i also think that i don't place a lot of
value on the military
[Music]
period no that yeah
i'd probably do one two
three you know you're more intelligent
than these [ __ ] come on bro
stop it four
five six i'm sorry i'm the bill in this
episode
okay i think one
two three four
five six i'm sorry oh sorry it's
hard for me to look past the education
part as a woman i had to fight hard you
know because people judge you and i look
like i'm the girl
that she would take the spring break
yeah i know you're six because you know
military you know i think there's a big
misconception about what goes on in the
military when you go in the military
it's not like you just you're handed a
gun and you're like alright well just
wait on your barracks until we go to war
and you shoot
everyone gets a job some people they
work on submarines and they work on
radars other people work
as artillery men other people work as
intelligence officers
other people who work in computer
sciences some people are lawyers
jagged jag i think they're called jack
some people work as divers some people
work as paramedics
some people work as doctors dentists you
could find
pretty much any job except it's for the
within the military so this idea
that like military people are somehow
stupider it's completely opposite
oftentimes they're
i would argue that the iq within the
military is far above the average iq of
the people in the general population
that's one
two you get education you get paid to go
learn a lot of people who join the
military get paid money they get paid to
go take courses
they get paid to take off-base training
they also get paid
to train on base within their craft if
you want to become good at something
provided it has good changeable skills
that would like divert towards the
civilian life there's a lot you can take
away from the military so this idea that
like military people are stupid i can
assure you
some of the most competent and that's
why when folks leave the military
a lot of them are super successful in
the civilian life if they chose a decent
trade
so that's i think a misconception that
people have because they don't know what
goes on
within the military one two three
four five six one immigrant
parents first generation going to
college humble
modest two me i don't know phd
cancer biology scientists i work in a
biotech company we make copic 19 testing
kits
stuff like that and then six it has
nothing to do with your background
i don't think you really have the
highest eq out of all of us
tyler he ranked last for me personally
because the way he carries himself
you're a [ __ ] white male he was
ranking intelligence based on his point
of view and not taking in other people's
point of views which is what you did
though but of course your way was the
right way so
okay and compiling results but really
just came down to his body language his
demeanor the way he carried himself the
way he acted towards the group
but the funny thing is that what was
what i
deemed arrogant is how she was acting
you know i mean
it's like she's looking at him being
like he arrogant
but i'm not looking at her like and i'm
saying he's just being
basic facts there's no there's a
difference between
arrogance there's a little more of
emotion in the arrogance it's like yeah
both in yourself where she's like
oh i would put myself first because well
you know phd
this and that not not that's arrogance
yeah that's boasting that's arrogance
definitely
she thinks her virtues and her education
are
justify her ideal self-importance
he feels like his training in the
military how well he's going how he does
a job
is his indication of his intelligence
the only difference is he didn't look at
you like you were arrogant but you
thought he was
because he valued those things you
understand what i'm saying it's like i
might think
i'm intelligent i don't because of how
much how much success i've had in my
work
my parkour the things that i've learned
along the way but you might look at me
like i'm being arrogant because you're
like those things
don't quantify or
make you or should make you think like
you are intelligent right so
it's just an interesting perspective
where a lot of people who have formal
education
think that's one of the only ways to
really come out as intelligent
and it's not the case whatsoever in fact
i would argue that intelligent
i would argue that school while it does
give you some resources to
learn how to problem solve is also so
structured in a way that it makes you
very limited in your problem
solving skills at times because it gives
you a test and it says
you will progress to the next level
provided you can pass this barometer
when real life is very abstract it's not
as easy or as
linear as school makes it out to be so
and also
and also school is really for
one type it's very union dimensional
yeah where it's work for one type of
people it's really
messed up that if you look at cell
phones within the last past
years it evolved so much if you look at
cars
it evolved so much in the past hundred
years if you looked at
just buildings the way we build things
the way we build uh buildings and houses
and stuff like that
that technology has evolved so much
but you take education and it's the same
way since
plato the way you listen to someone
talking in front of you
like and it really it's really
good for one type of person so it
doesn't showcase
it really doesn't showcase all
the potential of many different people
the people that excel
in school are good and but it doesn't
mean that those who don't excel in
school
are not also good in other places you
know i mean so
yeah yeah so again this doesn't mean
it's not a strong correlation between
education
and iq there definitely is i'm just
saying it's not a causation thing
and you can still find people who are
very highly intelligent but don't
necessarily have a formal educational
background
there are other forms of education as
well it's not just academia in school
there's also such thing as a education
on the field
right going through the process of
working through things and getting
better at your craft so just
keep that in mind all right please go
what do you think your number again is
most intelligent stupidest go for it i'm
gonna go asian
i'm gonna go white girl
army dude black girl i really want the
in real life just to teach you a lesson
but i got though
but i'ma put like [ __ ] maria and then
after that par puff
all right i'm gonna choose the same
thing as you but i'm gonna show my love
to power puff
listen you know what i'm saying my
little pony you're going fifth marine
i'll put you dead last okay
i know your family swam from cuba i'm
glad you made it to miami i'm glad you
guys are a great refugee story and you
made it you got your phd you're doing
covetous
congratulations you're going last i
think that i
sort of expected to be ranked a little
bit lower at first glance and first
interaction with me
it's hard to tell how intelligent i am
it's hard to tell how intelligent
anybody is
but i can't see how white you are and
how blonde you are so
get to the bottom stupid is anyone upset
with where they're standing
i think it makes sense that i'm down
here like the guy graduated from high
school and then joined the military he
probably wouldn't be
like high up on there hey you know
i'm okay i understand that but i'm about
to [ __ ] you
up if i was in their shoes i definitely
would have also ranked myself among the
lowest
i do feel like there might be a
prejudice acting in terms of ranking
you okay highly but i agree with the
ranking
i think it's a bit of prejudice as to
why you're first cause you're asian
but you know but i'm prejudiced you're
asian
[Music]
so number one is raymond number two
would be
kelly number three will be tyler
and number four would be shera number
five is shawn and number six is maria
[Music]
you're stupid nine plus ten yes you are
twenty one twenty one you stupid
all right all right look at this man
listen the minorities thought they were
getting reparations and the whites still
came up on top
look at them look at how happy they are
they've retained
their wealth they've retained their
wealth
oh look at the body language look at the
body language my man's just man
spreading
she's loving her life asian man still
like man you guys are still beneath me
maria's all mad in the corner over here
come on maria what happened with your
phd
10 bucks says they're gonna discredit
the iq test i think
an iq test tests something i don't think
it's intelligence it's definitely
testing something
iq tests are now known to be flawed and
like based on
incorrect sample sizes i have really
severe dyslexia
there's two questions on that test that
i automatically basically can't answer
i'm sure if you studied for an iq test
you would do a lot better yeah
iq tests are just one aspect or one way
to measure intelligence
it's really on a spectrum what
constitutes somebody that's intelligent
before this all i knew about iq tests is
that they
existed and the i stands for
intelligence
the i stands for intelligent and i am
intelligent
maria there's an eye your name but you
ain't intelligent it's not like me let's
go stop playing with me
this is my kind of people yeah
definitely your kind of people and let
me be clear about something it's not the
fact that he's military per se
what i don't like no no no this is the
kind of person i love to work with
oh okay yeah that's what you're saying i
love working with folks like this
straight to the point you ever ever like
we do comedy shows right and when we're
like launching
a show at a theater for example
sometimes you get a technician you give
him the specifications he comes all
right i'm gonna use this light this
light we're gonna flash it here this is
the cube bang bang bang
everything is seamless why because you
just work in specifics
and you set everything up accordingly
everything is just
i can work with that but when everything
comes in it's like i feel like and
based off of the cultural norms of this
and that well you know
you know there's the first layer where
oppression exists and then there's a
second layer where black folks exist
right like
i can't deal with that but this and then
there's private orange b
that's gonna come in and do the job
honey private hornsby
942 refrigerator tick but here's the
thing right
when you're working with people you just
want problem solving skills this is the
issue how do we get to the root of it
and to me that's the most useful people
to have around
especially in a crisis i don't have time
to deal with emotions
i don't have time to we don't have time
to okay we there's this shit's happening
we have to deal with that
let's go so yeah
emotion just all right let me let me
just look it up
i've never looked into iq tests before
coming here today i'm saying the
eq that was the first time i've ever
heard that term in my life let's go
let's go get tired of you and all this
eq stuff hey tyler
if i ever see you and you want a beer
it's on me brother
okay you have done your country proud
you have done the service members proud
you carry on doing whatever radar tech
[ __ ] you was doing
god bless you [ __ ] squirrel
coming back to intelligence it's not
just your iq it's your eq
it's your common sense it's street
smarts sure it is
some type of metric similar to an sat in
eight
oh you vex oh
sure sure like you know whatever this
would have been singing a different tune
if she came out first you already know
yeah of course you already know look at
her eyes look at the bags underneath her
eyes she already looked like she's
losing sleep
and it hasn't even happened yet it's a
metric for getting into college but
there's more to that person than that
test there's an irony here
in in her discrediting some kind of
academic tests
for saying like it doesn't measure
intelligence but then her using
education and academic tests that she
had to pass
to discredit others there's a bit of a a
double standard there that i think is
interesting
uh but shout out to my little pony he
said he was gonna be around fifth
six he came on fifth so you know that's
an upgrade for him too he's just happy
he's just like hey
rainbow relax
you already know let's go on top of that
it's like maria
lost but it was a landslide
yeah what i was saying the top was when
it was 136 then the other ones were
around 130
that my little pony was at what uh
123 or something so it's like
12 14 points difference from the
the the the the first person and then
and then maria lane slid
that thing down that drain like she
flushed that
it went it's over there it's like they
were bump bump
bump and then you throw it out over
there 112.
i guess you know it's bittersweet like
you know
peaches and cream
[Music]
the i the m
it's definitely not the m the a the r
the i a
but anyways yeah that's it for uh for
today's video you know at the end of the
day
it was cool it's a fun little video and
i always appreciate these kind of things
it shows some of her prejudices when it
comes to education it comes
through this and even i have these ideas
you know so you know don't be too hard
on me yeah we were clowning her this
whole thing but you know
listen i understand coming all the way
from cuba's heart so like god bless her
and uh hope she has a long and
prosperous life yeah live your life
but tell us what you guys think in the
video before you wreck yourself
foreign
[Music]
oh